[Music]  well the unlb football program like so  many programs around the country are  fighting that vicious virus multiple  tests have come back positive at unlv  school confirming to channel eight that  less than two and a half percent of the  football program  has tested positive for covid unlv were  now will not release the names or exact  number of those testing positive  but the positive tests include players  coaches and trainers in the program  and now they are in self-isolation for  10 days those who tested positive are  not practicing with the team  but practice has not stopped and the  program hasn't shut down the mountain  west is testing all athletes  in all programs now three times a week  the players test on monday wednesday  and friday unlv season opener october  24th against san diego state